hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
my daily driver smartphone for the last
two weeks has been the Samsung Galaxy
Note 4 so this is the follow-up
obviously to the note 3 and the biggest
change between the two is hardware so
right off the bat you get metal I talked
about this in my hands-on video a couple
weeks ago about how I was most impressed
with the new feel on the hand of this
phone and that's all come through you
get the black metal band all the way
around the device where it was plastic
before and it's chamfered at basically
every edge every corner so coming from
that super rounded super seamless feel
of the iPhone 6 plus this Note 4
actually feels kind of sharp at the
corners and the edges but it's honestly
definitely easier to hold because of the
flat sides and also being metal I have
increased hopes for durability obviously
having a metal frame should fare better
than plastic and so far it's held up
well so the back material is still
pretty similar to what you had on the
note 3 it's this soft touch faux leather
feel that honestly feels fine it's
pretty durable too even though it's got
a lot of crap for being not real leather
but it ditches the fake stitching look
and all that stuff from before so it's
just one smooth piece now and it's
removable and is soft and flimsy when
it's not attached to the phone obviously
but that's the point that's what allows
you to remove it and get access to that
removable battery and the micro SD card
slot but if you'll solve it and as soon
as you put it back on the phone you're
good so overall nothing can change the
fact that this phone is still big right
it's a 5.7 inch display and of course
you add bezels you add the home button
you add the earpiece and you're here
again pushing the limits of what people
will accept as a phone something you can
put in your pocket so what's interesting
about it is it's the same vertical
height roughly as the iPhone 6 plus but
it's a bit thicker to how's that huge
battery that I'll talk about in a second
and a bit wider from left to right but
for some reason when going from the
iPhone 6 plus to the note 4 the note
felt kind of compact despite having a
larger display which is weird but I want
to talk about this display it is pretty
gorgeous the Galaxy Note 4 is rocking a
5.7 inch quad HD Super AMOLED display so
it's big bright super high-resolution
super sharp
it has great outdoor visibility super
vibrant colors and basically any
environment has great viewing angles
great responsiveness basically it's the
best display on any smartphone right now
the best one I've used a lot and this is
the one I mean it's it's extremely
saturated it's not totally accurate yes
it has a strange pixel matrix but I love
this display because it's the only one
left that still impresses me every time
I turn it on it's a big part of why I
love this phone so much so crispy and
then it's up to TouchWiz on top of
Android 4.4 on this guy to utilize all
the space this huge screen now when you
talk about software on these quad HD
phones which have really all been
Android phones for the most part there
have been very few apps that totally
take advantage of all those pixels of
course you know there's Samsung's
properties so you get their crazy high
resolution wallpapers and their icons
and the whole TouchWiz user interface
everything there is optimized but if you
were expecting to download a whole bunch
of games or watch a whole bunch of
videos that are going to look way better
than they do on 1080p phones not so fast
I mean we're still waiting for that it's
still going to look good it's still a
big bright beautiful display but yeah
most games and apps out there are still
scaling from 1080p actually the one
thing that looks better from a higher
resolution point of view is web browsing
so all the text and images are
definitely sharper and you can at least
notice that and appreciate it
now if you've used or you're coming from
another Samsung phone like a note 2 or a
note 3 or a galaxy s3 or s4 the software
experience here is going to be really
familiar Samsung's added features of
course and now it's on top of the latest
version of Android but it's actually
promised to get Android 5.0 lollipop in
a couple of weeks so of course that will
be skinned like this and it'll look
nothing like stock Android and it will
continue to look like TouchWiz but touch
which still has the quirks I mentioned
when I reviewed the galaxy s5 now
preface this by saying my model I I got
very tired of Samsung's launcher and
keyboard so I installed Google now
launcher and a few keyboards but
everything else here is stock and for
the most part performance is great as
you would expect from a phone with a
quad-core Snapdragon 805 chip and three
gigs of ram and a super high end GPU
most stuff flies in app performance is
great scrolling frame rates and gaming
frame rates and just navigating through
the UI in general is very fast so
performance is awesome the only thing
that seemed slow pretty consistently is
when I press the multitasking button
there's always a brief pause before it
opened my carousel and then another
pause after I click the app and it waits
a second before it brings me in it's a
little slow
honestly the occasional touch was jank
lag is there when you're pulling down
the notification tray too fast or
something but that's you usually few and
far between so it's a very fast phone
other than the occasional TouchWiz jank
now when you have a huge phone with
top-notch specs like this and a massive
gorgeous super sharp display you really
want to take advantage of not just the
extra pixels but the whole package so
the one thing Samsung has been improving
from generation to generation
of the note lineup is the multitasking
options so of course you still have the
familiar holding down the back button
and being able to use two apps at once
so you split the display in half between
two of the supported apps and this
multitasking mode is smoother than ever
before it's just as useful since the
display is so big but you can copy and
paste text and information back and
forth between the panels it's more than
just two apps at once so it's really
great but a new multitasking feature
they've added is windowed apps so you
can with again supported apps dragged
down from the corner of the phone the
top corner to move your app into a
windowed size on top of everything else
and you can resize it and reposition it
wherever you want and it stays a live
app the whole time so you can interact
with it and keep it over stuff in the
background and everything still works so
you can also minimize them into these
little icon bubbles when you hit the
homescreen and activate them anytime you
want by tapping on them again so you can
have multiple window taps open at the
same time over the top of whatever
you're doing which is pretty nuts if you
ask me but this is the kind of stuff
Samsung has been doing and building in
to take advantage of the larger display
with all these extra pixels support for
this windowed stuff is still a small
list of apps kind of like the half
screen stuff so sometimes we'll pull
down from the corner window and it just
won't work it actually happened to me a
bunch of times also I'll be one handing
the phone and I'll go to pull down the
notification tray from the corner by
accident and it will shrink down the app
I'm using or tell me it's not supported
I don't know it's an interesting feature
with a slightly confusing implementation
at first but it can be really useful in
some niche situations
people will really like this when I get
to know it so my battery life experience
on the note 4 has been a little
interesting so I started off with the
international version of the note 4 it's
a Korean phone
it has different radios and it's looking
for different signals than the US
version would and it has an X nose chip
inside so it's a slightly different
SPECT model but it's a note 4
nevertheless but I was getting not so
high battery life a little bit
concerning that I had to plug in before
the end of the day I was getting three
to four hours of screen on time which is
a lot less than I would expect out of a
phone with a 3220 milliamp hour battery
but then I switched over to the one from
AT&T so I finally got my hands on a US
version of the Galaxy Note 4 so it has
all the correct radios now it also now
has the Qualcomm Snapdragon 805 chip
instead of the Exynos chip and I was
just blown away by the battery life so
the battery improves significantly I
started getting six and a half hours of
screen on time I never had to plug in
before the end of the day with the AT&T
model so if you're getting in the United
States obviously grab it from a carrier
and you will have absolutely no issues
with the battery life on the note 4 so
I'm happy to report thumbs up I
initially had concerns that I was
tweeting about but those are all gone
now so awesome battery life on the note
4 also as a bonus even though they
downgraded the charging port back to USB
2.0 he'd get fast charging and that gets
you half a charge in half an hour of
being plugged into the wall so not bad
for 30 minutes of charge and all this
comes with a phone that's just eight
point five millimeters thick so it's not
even that much thicker than the thinnest
phones out there so now the last major
change to the galaxy note 4 is the new
camera so it's a 16 megapixel camera
with optical image stabilization and
also you get 4k video and it takes
honestly the best imagery of any Samsung
phone yet so the characteristics of a
photo out of this camera would be really
vibrant photos and really sharp photos
and honestly it becomes super obvious
with this image processing that Samsung
is trying to sharpen everything in a
shot it basically applies a sharpening
filter over every image you take which
can look pretty decent sometimes but
even in a photo with a clear subject and
a clear background that should be
blurred and out of focus it still tries
to sharpen everything so you end up
sharpening the bokeh and getting these
weird artifacts on thin
that aren't supposed to be sharp and
honestly with 16 megapixels to play with
I don't think you need to do that much
sharpening at all I wish they would tone
that down it does take some very great
looking vibrant photos though especially
in daytime light and it gets a decent
amount of dynamic range even without
turning on that super overdone HDR mode
so I think people are going to like this
camera in most situations just like the
Galaxy s5 camera or the note 3 camera
and of course 4k video and stabilization
is a deadly combo so you can be shooting
wide here in 4k
check out dat zoom plus the optical
image stabilization oh is helps me stay
locked on whatever subject I'm at so I'm
20 yards away from these guys but again
since its 4k I'm not losing that much
detail and practically zoomed in on a
720p image of the frame and then zooming
back out of course will reveal the whole
4k image but it's pretty impressive
stuff for just a camera and a smartphone
and yes it is still sharpened 4k video
but it's going to look pretty good
anyway so there are some new other
features of the galaxy note 4 that I
don't use so much like a slightly
improved heart rate reader on the back
that monitor still works the slightly
improved fingerprint reader on the front
again I don't use that on the home
button that much but it's better
slightly improved speaker on the back oh
and a slightly improved s-pen in case we
forgot what the note series is all about
it's all about having a stylus and a big
screen so here's a rundown of the s-pen
just so we have it you take it out of
the back of the phone and it displays
four options on the screen you get
action memo smart select image clip and
screen right and you can even hover the
stylus over the display to see the names
of these and make your selection so
screen write takes a screenshot of
whatever is on your display and then
lets you write on it and crop it rotate
it whatever save it for later which is
nice smart select does something similar
it captures whatever is in your
selection and does its best to translate
it into text or something usable for
saving or sharing image clip lets you
make a free selection of anything on
your screen and share that and action
memo brings up a quick post post-it note
and then you can write on that post-it
and save it into S note otherwise you
can use it just like you would for your
finger swiping around moving in
naps typing stuff it's basically the
same functionality as the previous
stylist checking notifications you can
even touch the capacitive buttons too
and it will respond to that so at the
end of the day I have no problem saying
that the Galaxy Note 4 is the best phone
Samsung's ever made and of course it
should be it's their latest phone people
say this all the time but it's the best
display on the market and it's one of
the best built phones you can get right
now
it has an awesome battery life the specs
are top-notch higher than any other
Samsung device they put out in a long
time so this is the best phone I think
Samsung has ever made and I would have
no problem recommending it to anyone
searching for a large Android phone
obviously it's a lot bigger than some
others but it still feels more compact
in the hand like I've said than other
5.5 inch to 6 inch phones so in the
phablet territory as much as I hate the
word this is really the front-runner
right now and I have no problem
recommending the note 4 so there you
have it thank you for watching and if
you enjoyed it feel free to thumbs up
button below also the subscribe button
below should be read again thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one bass